welcome back to PJ chain Design This is
PJ today I would like to show you how to
make a infinity ring with the Bing with
very easy way in the Rhino 3D software
are you ready let's get
[Music]
started so that's starting from the
scratch we are going to uh come into the
front view and draw a circle and this
will be your ring size I'm setting up
for 16 mm you can set it up for whatever
size you want it and then we are going
to bring in a stone this stone is
available for you to download at the
link uh in the description below you
just need to sign up the newsletter and
then um you can download this Stone uh
first of all we need to decide how big
the stone we want it to be uh to sizing
the stone let me bring on the side we
can simply just go to use a 3D scale
tool and make make sure that you all
snap you wanted to uh make sure it is on
and your vertex is on and then we want
to snaping into this point to this point
so I basically want a stone to become
1.5
mm or less because I want to do the B
setting there so kind of moving the
stone back to the center we want to do
uh align centers and just type it zero
there okay and moving a stone to the
top so kind of give give us a guideline
for how big our crosssection need to be
now coming into the Right View I'm going
to draw a a square and the square with
the round corner so I'm going to click
on the Square with the round corner and
kind of set it up for the stone my stone
is 1.6 mm I actually wanted to have a
1.5 on each side so it will be 1.8 mm
let's take a look and see how it look so
1.8 by
1.8 right and then I want a corner to be
rounded just a little bit it will look
nicer on the render and that's moving
this uh Square back to the center on our
rail so make sure your midpoint is on
your quadrant is on on all snap and not
snapping it back so if our stone is
sitting right there it give us a little
bit room for the prong and also take a
look look on the top view you'll have a
little bit room there uh for Polish so I
think this is uh good to go all right so
now the second things I wanted to do is
because I want to make a turn so I need
to give them uh two cross-section so let
me just mirror that one to the
bottom and something like that okay now
if you done this before with the sweep
one you know this is the rail this this
is the cross section and I always tell
people say you need to have them align
so that way you will get the ring shank
and we close the sweep and we'll get
something like that so you will get the
ring shank is is something like this
look like a wire is been bending and the
direction everything is right I'm going
to move this one to the side for you to
compare so this time we're still going
to use the sweep one and we're going to
click this is the rail this is the
crosssection and we want everything line
up here right but what I like to do is
have it
spin additional 90° compared to the
original one and spin it back so I
actually want to move
this ahead like 90° and let's take a
look on that you can see that is kind of
rotated or spin it and then if you close
the sweep
then you will get something like this
let's click okay and take a look on that
if you spin it way too much let's say I
want to sweep one and uh PJ say I need
to align here align here and I feel like
I want to spin a lot more so I going to
go 90° and 180° and this is what's going
to happen is you're going to see this is
like cross 180° and then you get this
point and you're not able to print it
out this is not a valid um model uh to
print it out so be really really careful
okay so let me do one more time we want
to sweep one here and here and make sure
you want them to align really well first
and then moving 90° ahead and then so
that way you will get this twisting band
and uh we want to close the sweep and
that's how we get this
bin all right the second thing is we
need to uh arrange the stone so we need
to have a curve on on the surface in
order for us to arrange the stone so
let's go ahead to use extract the iso
curve and then we want to extract on
this surface that's snapping into the
midpoint
there so then our Stone will follow this
twisting surface and make a circle and
coming back and let's see if that work
we are going to use the array along the
curve and we have this stone is going to
array and follow this curve there all
right so notice that the orientation on
the one on the bottom is not right so we
kind of need to change it sometime what
you can do is you can change to roll
light and see if that working well but
actually it's not just flip it all right
so instead to using array along the
curve we do wanted to use along the
curve on the surface
so let's try this one select this object
the base point I'm going to select at
this midpoint here select the curve on
the surface we're going to pick up this
uh curve we extract from the surface and
we're going to pick up this surface so
notice that now it will floting really
nicely on it but now how many do we need
it I'm not so sure so I'm going to click
it here as a divide and I'm going to try
36 and see how it goes and it actually
went pretty well so that's hit enter so
one thing I want to point out here is we
were measuring for 1.5 mm Stone and then
uh the width should be okay but once
it's turn around the surface is no
longer um wide enough or compensates the
stone right there right so in fact we
might need to have the stone get smaller
to make the stone a little bit smaller
so let's try one more time we wanted to
do the transform array along the curve
on the surface and so we pick up the
object snapping here and this is our
curve this is the surface and since the
stone is smaller so I need to try more
of them so maybe I want to try
48 and see how it
goes it seems to look really nice there
now next we need to making the prong you
can have the full prong or you can have
the Shar prong make it a straight line
and I simply just need to pipe it for
whatever diameter you think is suitable
okay so then I'm going to moving this
one over
here as a share prong and then I also
want to mirror to the other
side to be symmetrical so then we will
have the prawn there that's moving this
prawn
down like this and we're going to use
the same command uh let's do the
transform
array along curve on the surface and
then we want to pick up the base point
we want to pick the same point right
here like we did on the stone and then
this is the curve this is the surface
and we actually want to divide it the
same way for 48 of them and that's how
we get this one
there once we have done that we want to
copy for what we did uh on the side of
over here so let's go ahead to extract
the iso curve and we want to extract um
this surface snapping into the midpoint
right there okay what we wanted to do
next is pick up this mesh
here and I want to pick up two
prong polish surface and this polish
surface and simply mirror to the other
side like this so this time we want to
starting from the bottom uh to be easy
to tell I'm just going to changing the
color
so that's changing this into the red and
that's changing the stone
into the green so let's go ahead to use
the same command array along curve on
the surface and we're going to pick up
this one the base is going to be
snapping into the quadrant there and the
Curve will be this one the surface will
be this one okay so notice that they are
upside down and there actually there's
nothing in the option for you to change
it right so I find is the easiest way
instead of go to you know changing the
direction and everything I'm going to
record a
history and I'm coming into the divide
and with the same number with the
history recorded okay and hit enter
right so they all appear upside down but
it's actually facing uh the right angle
on the ring so what I wanted to do is
pick up this original
one on both poly surface there and
because I recorded history I'm going to
flip it
180° back here and then I'm going to
move it down to the surface like that
all right so instead of you know trying
to figuring out all the direction and we
simply can do that and I'm just going to
move this back to the center and double
checking if everything is flow nicely
and once we are done we can delete this
original one and it will say it will
delete the history but that's fine and
that's how you make this infinti Rim
band do you enjoy the stone setting and
want to learn more I have a stone
setting mini course and it's completely
free specific design for the beginner
wed to learn jewelry cat and understand
how the stone is setting for the cat
design I will start talking about the
stone setting concept and use a basic PR
set as a practice and I'll also show you
how to customiz your own design for the
prong set I'll put the link in the
description below hope to see you in
that mini course thank you for watching
and I will see you next
[Music]